Speaking of which, um, so lately I've been
doing these longer youtube live streams.
I had an hour or 75 minute sort of debate
conversation with Steven Banal, who's a streamer
known as destiny.
We talked about add boycotts as a strategy
in politics.
Last week I did a 75 minute conversation with
Tim Pool, an independent journalist about
free speech and platforming and Twitter.
There were some disagreements, there were
some agreements, but in both cases we took
about 60 or 75 minutes to figure out in more
depth what do we agree about, what do we disagree
about?
And people seem to be really liking the format
if not always the specific people that I'm
interviewing.
So my question to you is, who else do you
want me to quote, debate or have a conversation
with in which we explore disagreements?
Um, I know a lot of people often say debate
Ben Shapiro.
I think that, uh, he's probably too big for
the show at this point.
Rightly or wrongly.
I think that that's the perception at this
point in time.
So I don't know that he would do it, but if
he did, what would the topic be?
I'm open to ideas.
Um, some of the folks you suggest, maybe we've
already reached out to others not, but uh,
let me know who you would like to see in a
long form conversation with me and we'll try
to make it happen.
Um, I will also have some in person stuff
to announce soon as well.
These aren't 100% finalized so I won't give
all the details yet, but in the next six to
eight months I will probably be doing an in
person event in Rochester, New York, which
will be open to the public for a small fee.
It'll be part of a broader conference and
I'm insisting that they make just that event.
Just my, my talk open to the public for a
small fee without having to sign up for the
entire conference.
Um, I've got something coming up in Texas.
I'm not even going to say where in Texas yet,
but I will have more details about that.
La is looking more and more likely I'll, although
I don't know if that will be public appearances
are just a few interviews which I might be
doing.
Um, but in any case, everything I do for an
organization or a conference, I always insist,
let's make it open to the public, at least
with a ticket, not just conference participants
or members of your organization.
And usually most people are open to that.
Uh, speaking, invitations, get in touch using
the contact form on the website.
2019 is filling up and I'm, I'm actually already
looking at from 2020 events.
So get in touch and I'll just say ahead of
time because people later get mad.
There does have to be a budget.
You know, at this point I'm, I'm lucky enough
to get enough requests where I don't have
to travel on my own time across the country,
uh, and uh, uh, pay my own way there for unpaid
events.
But I do work with organizations that have
a variety of budgets, so it's always worth
getting in touch, uh, and at at least three
very exciting things to announce in the very,
very near future.